[Music]
introducing
the gutties
yeah welcome to the goodies where we
announce our best and worst of the year
awards it's the only show where the
trophy is taller than the presenter
now this type of year-end list has never
been tried in the history of television
no one's ever done this so we're super
excited about breaking new ground all
right first up biggest hypocrite of the
year i'll kick it off with gavin newsom
his idea of social distancing is to eat
in a restaurant so expensive that it'll
never run into any working-class people
but let's take it around the panel jamie
hypocrite of the year you crushed it
with that call that was that's a great
one i'm gonna have to go uh i'm gonna go
fauci
i'm gonna go fauci i it's so much
hypocrisy even the mask thing i'm saying
to wear a mask where he said there were
two masks at one point that's not
wearing a mask for your mask yes and
then he was seen at a baseball game with
no ma if we weren't going for this year
i would have to go uh arnold noble
as the biggest hypocrite you know this
he was the guy that invented the
nobel peace prize right and he went on
to invent dynamite yes
there's not a lot of peaceful uses
that's true that's true good point very
good tyrus hypocrite of the year uh it's
a group yes it takes a family mm-hmm cnn
[Music]
reason
any reason do you need a reason
have you not watched the news lately yes
yes yes yes it's amazing how they focus
yes yeah i don't know
they uh they never keep wowing us and
i'm also exciting because let's get
after it's available so
yes you know if anyone here is looking
for a catchphrase it doesn't work yes
yeah we didn't know what let's get after
it meant like what now we do what was
the it now we do
cat biggest hypocrite and i'm glad you
woke up thank you
i'm not
uh i think that was either gavin newsom
is a good call but it wasn't just him it
was a lot of people yeah you know it was
cheated to leave at the wedding it's all
these people who are making rules for
other people and then not following
themselves and then not really caring or
changing their minds when they do get
caught not following them not saying
okay let's change the rules but just
saying
and then just waiting for it to go over
and continuing to do so dana what is
your hypocrite of the year well in a one
week period you had what cats talking
about with the mayor of chicago the
mayor of dc and the mayor of san
francisco all in one week at social
events where everybody else was expected
to wear a mask especially if you think
about nancy pelosi that was all in the
same week when she had when she went to
that big event big dinner but every
staff member had to wear a mask and i
actually i've i've started to really
hate going into restaurants where
everybody else has to be masked but the
people who are actually eating so
hopefully that can change in 2022 but i
think that those three mares really took
the cake
took the cake nicely done at the
restaurant i kind of like the servers
wearing masks because then they can't
tell you about their screenplay
greg i have a
i have a solution if you ever like on a
plane and they go you have to wear a
mask when you're eating what i'll do is
i'll buy a hundred pound bag of
sunflower seeds very good yeah
oh we're landing oh you're that guy
all right to the next award tool of the
year this is tough there are so many
tools for me it's a tie between seth
rogen chris cuomo and adam kinzinger
seth blamed his new show tanking on
white supremacists and chris he was a
giant tool even before helping his
brother stave off sexual harassment
allegations and after being emotionally
broken by trump adam just chases the
media spotlight looking for strange new
respect so cat who is the tool it's
easily chris cuomo even if none of that
stuff were true just anybody who would
ever say let's get after it is a tool
and then of course he also faked his own
new you know
naked on the internet accident yeah yeah
because he's like always got his shirt
off once i ever see his he's he's the
biggest tool maybe in the history of the
planet
it's a big night for cnn brian stelter
they're just bringing the awards home i
guess that's true he is that he's hoping
it's made of chocolate yes well either
way
you made it chubby here you go
dana tool let's keep it going with
jeffrey toobin oh there you go
[Applause]
i asked the audience to give him a hand
but he doesn't need it
tubing i want you to elaborate just to
watch you have to talk about it but i'm
not
because i'm a friend all right tool
jamie i'm mixing it up here yeah i'm
going with danny carey do you guys know
danny carey no who's that danny carey is
the drummer
from tool yes that actually got accused
of like uh like her harassment sexual uh
then he yelled homophobic slurs oh this
was at the tsa that's right at the tsa
and you know i had the only thing i'd
rather listen to less than homophobic
slurs is the band tool really yeah so
that's my tool of these i i like they
had their first album was pretty good
i'm gonna be honest i'm not familiar
with it but thought it'd be a good joke
yes
so i won't press
all right up next the most racist event
of the year my pick is every classroom
teaching critical race theory coming in
a close second anyone who is currently
employing joyride tyrus what do you
about
think
wedding what's the most racist oh the
most racist thing ever
this year
cnn again domino
we're all white supremacists we're all
white supremacists even you even me
which is exciting because it's nice to
know they open their doors to us so yes
yes very interesting mixer now yeah well
you know even even races need diversity
yeah right you know what apparently
which was kind of weird if that makes
them the hypocrites of the year exactly
yes that's true who did i not go to yet
dana so i don't know if this qualifies
but help me because this is the story
that stuck with me a lot which is um
when the biden administration accused
the mounted border patrol of being
racist because they were actually doing
their jobs using their horses in order
to to prevent migrants from illegally
entering the united states and then they
said that the the president himself said
they will pay yes he said there would be
an investigation lo and behold guess
what they dropped the investigation
declined to investigate and just like
try to let this go i don't really want
to let it go yeah no it's true it's like
they're
counting on the news cycle to erase
everything jamie what's your vote you
know what i thought was super racist the
uh biden closing the border uh like not
allowing travel from uh south africa
mm-hmm several other countries i thought
that was kind of rare but that was like
maybe because i that reflected me
personally greg i had a big tour i was
doing the comedy hut in botswana yes and
um
i was i was doing laughs laughs chuckle
hut in zimbabwe yes um
here's just to know in the year coming
up here's how to spot a racist if you've
ever had bad bath and beyond yeah and
you see someone with sheets and they're
going into the changing room yeah yes
nice that's how you know last uh dana uh
cat like i don't know like i'm saying
it's probably not an event it's probably
like it's like guys on the internet in
their mom's basements typing racist
stuff
but that's going on all the time and
also yeah
that's all i have to say i'm very good
all right up next worst politician of
the year who could that be aoc it's hard
to smash the system at an event that
serves hors d'oeuvres
combo's always good for laughs if laughs
mean that noise that
sounds like a dying goat
and justin trudeau is one more blackface
than most coal miners
all right what do you think uh worst
politician jamie i'm gonna go
maybe a weird one but i'm gonna go with
de blasio yeah ah no that was mine took
mine is that yours yes yes
yes you want me to change it yeah could
you change it to cnn then tyrus will
have nothing
no we could just all say deposits
different reasons i'll say my least
favorite thing was the was the vaccine
thing where he was eating the hamburger
and fries yes
because what an insane i just in general
feel like if you're gonna push vaccines
you should
push a healthy lifestyle for god's sakes
and he's on tv going like hey if you get
the vaccine you get free co-morbidities
yes
gain that weight yeah yes uh what's your
reason for the blood
i think that
you have united new yorkers and being
excited about eric adams right that's
yeah i mean so it takes it takes
somebody that bad in order to get it
done there's a lot riding on eric adams
like hopefully he can turn things around
but de blasio is so bad that he doesn't
even realize how
disliked he is so now he wants to run
for governor yeah exactly he ran for
this is my reason is that while the
crime was exploding he was running for
president as it was starting he was and
he got he got less than one percent i
think and he it still didn't stop him i
think eric adams has a great opportunity
because it's always good to come in
after the worst mayor in history cat
what's your choice i would say andrew
cuomo i mean
which i i mean he was like he killed
grandparents and then he was like
groping women and then like using
taxpayer dollars to make himself rich
and he's just the worst and i think it
shows a lot of maturity on my part that
i am you know no longer like a man with
nipple rings
there you go tyrus uh lightfoot
lightfoot oh nice hands down we'll only
speak to
brown reporters
and basically told realtors they were
getting robbed and put out of business
it's because you dressed that way yeah
yeah you must have been asking for it
mm-hmm so i think hands down that among
a list of many other things is probably
the worst politician in the country oh
yeah that's pretty good i'm again i'm
gonna go de blasio just because he's
just the worst human being i think i've
ever seen ever on the planet well that
might be too but no that's okay of
course if we have the worst then we have
to give credit to the best politician of
the year you could say president of
florida
ron desantis
he's done he's done more for florida
than plastic surgery
what do you say cat i know i don't
idolize politicians
i don't idolize anybody
except for adam sandler
maybe that's actually true i know that i
know i know so you have no i don't know
i don't because it's like they work for
all of us and so they can keep working
all right what about you tyrus
i'll go with paul ryan paul i had rand
paul well i stole your notes ha ha
i didn't see the kissing thing though i
missed that but uh he just seemed to
stay the course and it didn't matter
whether he was agreed upon or booed he
just he did the job and i respect that
and he he stood up to things and
philadelphia he even got beat up by his
neighbor and he still went to work so
yeah you gotta count for something but
yeah that's true his consistency is is
honorable yeah consistency is annoying
but it's honorable dana what do you say
i think it is ron desantis in my mind
that he's been able to bridge this last
two years and and um
i remember being down in florida for
something and uh had an uber driver
and he said i love our governor i love
our governor he said i'm really afraid
he's going to run for president because
then he won't be our governor anymore
and i thought wow he is penetrated right
like there's obviously there's applause
here but i do think that his approval is
not just because he's a great politician
but he's been a pretty effective
implementer of policy uber driver must
be nice
jamie i would
i'm gonna have to oh i think my answers
were all stolen i got to go with the
same answer i think florida knows what
they're doing i feel like they i don't
know they somehow came out on the other
side of this whole thing
like fine
i was in an uber
i'm in an uber in florida yeah and the
guy i go you guys aren't doing like
we're not social distancing anymore
we're not masking you guys are doing so
great he goes we're not doing anything
and i believed him because i was sitting
on his lap and he said um
and then he goes
here's why i love florida part of the
this is what just an uber driver said so
it might not be true yeah part of the
first tier opening when they open stuff
up at drakovic he said part of the first
tier was uh strip clubs open in the
first tier in florida yeah and he goes
you got to get down there and he goes
it's a buyer's market
and i go what do you tell he goes the
deals are incredible no and i'm not
normally a strip club guy but i went
down there just for research yeah and um
it was crazy it was like five dollars a
dance and for 20 bucks they would take
you in the back room and give you covet
[Laughter]
nicely done hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else